welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question the show that gives you
too much information about the wild
wandering which is like wanda maximoff
and whether or not an enforced monarchy
is good for
government structure
that caught me off guard well i'm eric
boss laughing it up here with marina
mastros how you doing marina
hi everybody i'm good i have a new
background and my
house is real echoey because i just
moved so yeah oh
we got to fill it in with some uh some
nice tapestries yeah this is my only
piece of furniture so
ah well as we're wondering where marina
is we are also wondering where rwanda is
what's our big question this week marina
eric where is wanda in the one division
post credit scene
and where is everything in the mcu
ah yes we're now kind of in between
marvel's stuff right
so one division ended with wanda in some
weird mountainside location
studying the dark hold with her astral
projected self while her corporeal form
is sipping tea
and we don't really know where she is
but we're also looking ahead to the
falcon the winter soldier coming up this
weekend
right and we know that's going to be
visiting some interesting locations
looks like it's going back to sokovia
for a bit but it's also going to be
expanding the map to madrapore
which is a whole new uh horizon a whole
new front
of the mcu and i think now is the
perfect time
to look at the map we there's so much on
the mcu map that we don't
know it's not just the normal world of
earth there are other little countries
that the mcu is now carving out
and i love that i think it's such an
exciting time so
uh to answer this question to get an
idea of where wanda might be hiding out
we're gonna look at some of the place
the mcu has already been
but also look ahead at some potential
vacation destinations that future films
might take
us so grab your magnifying glasses gum
shoes
we're gonna fill out the map of the mcu
as we span the globe and ask
where in the world is what the max ma
off did i do it
did i get there you did you did i was
like he's gonna be off key and then you
weren't no i dropped that octave
marina you're from san diego so you're
like our car in san diego
uh hell yeah i'll take it i'm i'm from
l.a originally but i lived in san diego
for like a decade so
marina you lived in san diego for ten
years uh let's get a sense of our globe
just by filling in some areas that we
already
know exist because they're places that
exist in our world so we know of new
york that's where the battle of new york
happened that's where steve rogers
began peter parker began in queens st
rogers in brooklyn sanctum sanctorum
there's a location in in mexi
we also know berlin that's you know uh
in germany of course that's where uh
red skull he had that pinned as uh
target that way they were gonna go bomb
berlin their own nazi
benefactors just because we have the
same enemy doesn't make his friends
hydra sorry
because it's easy to have nazis on your
[ __ ] list that doesn't make you a good
person just yeah
bottom of the barrel yeah that's the
least you could do but yeah we know
berlin for the mcu that's where the big
civil war airport battle took place
we know there's a joint
counter-terrorism task force
place that's that's in berlin spider-man
far from home went there
and then uh of course uh nigeria city of
lagos or
lagos we know in the mcu they call it
lagos so if we're saying it wrong we're
sorry we're just going by what
the mcu does um that's where the big
civil war
issue was where wanda accidentally
killed a bunch of people and
uh they tried to get crossbones london
uh london has its own sanctum sanctorum
and there's a lot of stuff there
steve rogers was there for a bit um jane
foster
was in london where the whole thor the
dark world the best mc film according to
my pin tweet
did the internet get you for that uh
they don't understand it
that's typical par for the course of
course siberia there's a hydra base in
siberia
that's where bucky was kept you know
before he was deployed
and marina have you been to any of these
places yeah i've been to
berlin london and siberia no
you will be once putin has his way he's
going to lock us all up in some gulags
yup yup the other two i have though yes
wow you're pretty well traveled i've
been to
london uh in new york but not to berlin
it's a very cool city very cool city
because
they have this is why it's cool eric
because they have their own uh dedicated
sidewalk lane and a bike lane
so the two don't have to compete like
you're not like in the bike in the
street
or sharing a bike with like the walking
pathway which is just like blows my mind
as a person who lives in l.a
so if you're trying to ride back in l.a
you like die
they have sidewalks and bike lanes in a
lot of parts of l.a
mm-hmm that's not unique to berlin
you're right you are right they're too
uncommon they're too uncommon and most
of the time
sidewalks have [ __ ] on it too you're
right about that eric's being nice but
it blew my mind when i got to bill and i
was like oh my god
they're like well we have all this
history and this is called no no just
taking pictures of the ground yeah
have you been to uh santa monica and
venice how they have the bike path that
goes down and it's separated and um
one of kelly and mai's first dates is we
went on a bike we ran
some bikes and we went down and people
will just walk in the bike path of it
not realizing it's supposed to be
separated and kelly
is not afraid to confront she goes up
before he goes ding ding ding
you're walking in the bike lane and
people were still like whoa that's great
and i was like i love this woman i need
this woman in my life
she does not give a [ __ ] what anyone
thinks of her in
any situation that's what i heard i knew
before that but that's what i really
really knew
confirmed she's the best confirmed i
should have proposed right then and
there i at least could have done it
away from our homes instead of waiting
till we were in coven i'm such a
freaking idiot
let's talk about some places that are
just fictional locales that
the mcu has established on this map so
we're gonna put some pins in there too
starting with the one we just visited in
one division west view so west view is
located somewhere in new jersey
apparently inland
because we never really see a coastline
there it has a population of
3 892 but a lot of people compare it to
leonia new jersey
uh it is a real town that vision and
scarlet witch lived in during the run in
the 80s comics
uh there is an unincorporated community
named west
view two words that is adjacent to lunia
and in the penultimate episode on one
division title previously on we see the
new jersey zip code as
0801 which corresponds to
a real world location of annandale new
jersey have you been to annadel
marina yes actually no i have this is
like a travel show starring marina
are there bike lanes though yeah that
i'm there
we also know about the new avengers
compound this is located upstate new
york and it's somewhere along the hudson
river
this was previously an old stark
property where
howard stark kept a bunch of stuff uh
but that's where the avengers get
headquartered after they
move out of the city and then it's
currently as of uh the current timeline
has been wrecked by uh the battle of
earth by thanos's forces
he he flattened it pretty much yeah it
would have gotten flooded but doctor
strange was doing such a good job with
irrigation during that battle
he's like this is all i will do during
this battle is just make sure no one
drowns he just made him go backwards
it just yeah it looked cool that's all
that matters it actually really did
so another new place on the mcu map from
one division was sword hq now we're not
given a firm location on this but based
on
the photography of it it's a coastline
it's kind of swampy
topography it looks like somewhere on
the east coast of florida probably
somewhere near cape canaveral because it
look has a very similar look to the cape
canaveral launch pads
and i believe the license plates in the
parking lot were florida license plates
when wanda
took her was that a buick the red one
it's cute
everyone else drives like oddies in the
mcu but one is like
no i'm gonna go for the lower tier
enterprise rental she's a witch she
could teleport there and she's like no i
will drive i want to give me a sensible
car
so sokovia is another location that uh
we saw a bit of in one division and
baron zemo will be visiting
in a falcon winter soldier because
that's where he's from it's somewhere in
central southeastern europe it's
bordered by slovakia in the czech
republic yeah this is where wanda and
pietro's parents were killed
uh and then sokovia was also located in
the hydro research base
where uh von strucker experimented on
them with the mind stone
we went back there we saw that moment
where that happened ultron
was murdered there he wasn't murdered he
was put down
and he might still be alive but we can't
say murder there he wasn't like
he was shopping and someone stabbed him
and he's like sounds like you're on his
side
eric he was murdered it just came out it
just came out that way
he was unceremoniously slain so this is
one place that wanda might be
based off of the terrain it's very
mountainous she might have gone back to
a part
of sokovia there just had a nice little
cabin where she could have you know
just chilled out yeah that's what i
would do yeah would you go back
after you had the most dramatic thing
would you go back to your birthplace or
would you just go somewhere as far away
as you could like
yeah so what would you do i was actually
thinking about this after the end of one
vision
because she's had so many traumas in her
life and i was like why isn't she a bad
person
because i've also been listening to a
lot of podcasts about serial killers
it's it's i'm all over the place i'm all
over the place
but she should like she very easily
could have been a bad person by the end
of this like we would understand
but her family is happy
they are happy together and she was
raised by good people so if it was me
and honestly most human beings want to
go back to where they're most
comfortable so
i would and it totally strikes me as a
very high possibility that she would
just go back to her home
find a nice spot in the woods and like
go back to the memories of her
early family that she can just like
chill out
and you know process her grief and
really go through her trauma in a
healthy way
yeah i think so i i agree that with her
going to west view after sword is like
we will not give you your husband we
will give you a chance to say goodbye to
scraps uh a room is grasped
but her mission to go back to west view
was to go back to hopefully berry vision
and that's the home that he wanted for
them yeah she's just trying to find
what's home for her avengers compounds
wrecked you know the only person that
she really loved i mean she had that
connection with hawkeye
so i could see her maybe going back to
missouri but they don't got those kind
of mountains in missouri let's get back
to other places on the mcu map camp
lehigh of course that's nearby west view
that is an army facility in wheaton new
jersey
we visited there in the first cat movie
we visited there in winter soldier and
an end game
and arnhem zola's mega brain computer
was there and kind of ruined the world
from that little basement there so
now let's talk about the new one that
we're visiting falcon winter soldier
magipore
so this is in uh it's near singapore
it's uh in southeastern asia we don't
know a lot about the principal
of match report in the mcu yet we're
about to learn a lot more but in the
comics
it is located in the strait of malacca
that's between malaysia and indonesia
it's heavily based on singapore except
in this one it's kind of split between
uh upper upper class and a lower level
class it's kind of a haven for criminals
you have the super wealthy elite like
crime lords who live up and look down
on the lower level like you know human
traffickers drug dealers
you know it's super impoverished low
down actually
fun fact maria hill was said to have
been stationed in major poor as a shield
agent at some point according to the
avengers the shield
files book so we have the wakanda files
we have the shield files so maybe we'll
we'll get her tied in
yeah yeah i don't think one is in
magipore there they don't have a ton of
huge mountains like that that are
snow-capped because it's a very warm
climate down there
but they have a lot of ties with the
hand
with uh yeah that you could set up shang
chi
there you know there's that's right a
whole side of the world there that's
fascinating
totally that we haven't really totally
seen wakanda
the kingdom of wakanda that is a
landlocked country
in africa it's basically the superior
nation on earth based off their
technology and their
level of society's evolution it's
somewhere near uganda
uh and it's all based on this
heart-shaped herb this uh vibranium
meteorite that crashed there and formed
mount bashenga director ryan coogler
stated that his depiction of wakanda
was inspired by the kingdom of lesotho
which is just kind of isolated but very
rich in culture
oh sick so i don't think wanda is an uh
wakanda because that would be such a too
fun of a word play
wanda and wakanda
yeah two rhymey and i don't think they
would want her there they'd be like get
out of here we don't want to become the
next west view oh hell no
karen keep your brand ass potato salad
to yourself obviously we're gonna be
revisiting wakanda
and hopefully a lot of stuff not just
black panther too it's there it's like
that should be the capital of all things
in the mcu now because it's like the way
things were just set in new york because
that's kind of the world gravitates
around new york yeah the world should
gravitate around wakanda now that's
basically
dope so we also have the location of new
asgard that's located in tonsburg norway
and this is another place that keeps
getting revisited so we first saw it in
the first thor movie actually we first
started the first cat movie that's where
that church was where odin kept the
tesseract
but then it was tied in with thor
because that's where we saw the battle
that led to
odin's relationship with the norwegians
there and that's where the asgardians
resettle to form
new asgard and avengers end game so they
have huge
huge mountains up in norway for sure
yeah but i don't think it would be that
didn't look like a coastline
area where wanda was that kind of looked
more inland it could have been a fjord
it could have been a fjord we didn't see
what that body of water connected to
but normally fjords are between two
steep mountain cliff sides this was kind
of like a mountain lake on a field
and there's some some trees so it could
have been norway i
a lot of people were saying this looked
like where bruce banner was
at the end of the ed norton hulk uh
because
like wanda he's kind of like i need to
get away from society just kind of yeah
meditate drink some tea um similar
character journeys
uh that was in canada i don't think
wanda was in canada people are gonna get
mad at me for this but like nobody wants
to go to canada that flag is a [ __ ]
leaf
i want to go to canada not uh rural
canada but
i love when i've been to montreal and
i want to go to like uber all right
another important location we got to
talk about commerce
uh yeah that's the headquarters of all
the sorcerers where steven strange met
the ancient one and wong and all those
great folks uh that is located in
kathmandu that's the capital city of
nepal
so that's an important location it's
linked with the uh the sanctums in hong
kong
and in london and in new york so it's
kind of like the nexus point for those
three sanctums
it feels like in its own kind of secret
realm place that is lifted above
just kathmandu because i don't think
everyone in kathmandu is like oh yeah
camera dodgers over there
yeah i i delivered a couple pizzas over
there
great tippers a lot of new yorkers get
sucked in and they end up
in nepal and they're like wow this is
lolly long delivery
oh boy to take a couple flights to get
here but that pizza's so good from new
york it's worth it
time so uh of all the places we've
talked about let's
zero in on some ones that wanda might be
in so one
option is alkali lake that is in alberta
canada
homeland of ted cruz so
it sounds like mutants are coming to the
mcu uh we don't know when
exactly but if they are uh wanda maximov
is a total mutant
she might go someplace around that
that's pretty remote
um now alkali lake is important for the
government
weapon x base that was there on the
other side of the lake i don't i think
it'd be pretty coincidental
she's like oh those trucks that are
going by all the time and waking me up
they're
making wolverine maybe i should help
them
while wolverine is important to house of
m uh his
backstory isn't totally tied in with
wanda maximoff's backstory so i
i don't think it's going to be less
likely now there is a kingdom of
latviria
the homeland of dr doom that's right
that's going to be some kind of eastern
european country it's supposed to be
bordering like hungary
serbia montenegro area the transylvania
region of romania
um it kind of moves around a lot there's
been a lot of thought that maybe dr doom
could tie in with multiverse of madness
maybe wanda could be used to bring in
doctor doom and this is where she meets
them
yeah he allows her residency there but
there is some famous mountains uh in
latvia there's mount victorium the
viscayan mountains the carpathian
mountains
mount sorkista which is the home to the
demon sorceress pandemonium
so that's another possible place yeah it
could be it'd be a fun tie-in
uh we should talk about jenosha jenosh
is coming to the mcu that's a republic
of genocia
that's a small crescent-shaped island
off the eastern coast of africa
north of madagascar and that's where
uh magneto sets up like a mutant society
there in genocia it's kind of like all
right you guys can go there
magnet is like good that's what i want
you didn't kick me out i kicked myself
out
go i'm gone kill that well i am and the
thing about jenosha
is that it is uh it ties into house of m
because scarlet witch is brought to
genocide by magneto after she has a
nervous breakdown
and that's when professor x tries to
help her but he's not able to do so
before reality begins to shift for
everyone
so this could be kind of where house of
them starts but the place
i like best for where in the world is
one of max wolf is vuenegor mountain oh
because that's an important place to
wanda's origin and her ancestry it's uh
she was born in the citadel the high
evolutionary and it's where
it's uh the demon cathan or chauthon
wrote the darkhold
which is where the darkhold was you know
just in the mcu and then magda gave
birth to juan and pietro there the high
evolutionary had uh one of the
evolved creations of bova who was their
um nursemaid and bova showed up in one
division in that episode two animated
intro
and a lot of people were thinking the
high evolutionary could come into the
mcu in guardians of the galaxy vol 3
that it might have been the high
evolutionary who created rocket
ah because all of them need to be
rocket had lila who's an otter that was
his past love
and that's a big mystery of who created
rock yeah
so that might be he was resident of
there and then he might have gone to
some other like to half world where his
rockets origin and created all those
things there
yeah totally herbert windham interesting
dude i love
answering a question from a separate
movie and then finally wrapping it up in
like a different
area i like cross
things where it's like we didn't forget
we're actually still keeping track of
all this stuff
we're also probably gonna visit atlantis
at some point uh
we're probably gonna visit uh
westchester
county new york that's where the
x-mansion is so there's lots of cool
horizons that are gonna be visited
but uh other than someplace far away
of all these places marina where would
you bet uh wanda is hiding
my bet is uh sokovia just that's where
i'm placing my bets now so the internet
can tell me i'm wrong later
yeah it's fun it's funny
uh yeah just for the same reasons that i
said earlier she
she has now emotionally matured enough
to be able to
go back home so she was running running
running running away from that
but now one division has helped her
embrace her own reality or real reality
now she's able to and i like the
emotional arc
of that storytelling of like now that
she can go home she will and she does
i think so too i could totally see that
we'll see if this uh location is
important i hope it is important because
a lot of important things are happening
there and the way that she's looking
into the dark hold
that could be the center of where
reality starts to get rewritten or a
giant hell mouth could form in that lake
and down into it
before we continue we want to thank some
friends who helped us make this episode
thank you to imperfect foods
for sponsoring this episode of big
question every year billions of pounds
of food go to waste
and often it's because that food doesn't
just live up to the strict cosmetic
standards of grocery stores
imperfect foods it's on a mission to
reimagine the grocery delivery for a
kinder less
wasteful world they deliver sustainable
affordable groceries including produce
quality protein
eggs and dairy and pantry staples
straight to your door plus they find
tasty new discoveries for you to try
each week
sign up and create your flexible
personalized grocery plan and then shop
online each week and get affordable and
sustainable groceries delivered directly
to your door with imperfect foods
grocery shopping fits seamlessly into
your life and every week is a tasty
adventure
sign up with imperfect foods today to
save time save money and save food from
going to waste and right now imperfect
foods is offering our audience 20
off plus free shipping on your first
order when you go to imperfectfoods.com
and make sure to use a promo code big
question so try imperfect foods now and
for a limited time get 20
off plus free shipping on your first
order go to imperfectfoods.com and use
bigquestion to sign up that's 20
off plus free shipping at
perfectfoods.com offer code big question
this episode is also brought to you by
final space which is back for its third
season starting saturday march 20th on
adult swim so you can stream the first
two seasons of olin rogers animated
space adventure on hbo max right now to
get all caught up
with the crew trapped in final space
gary in the team squad
are desperate to find a way home the
fate of the galaxy hangs in the balance
final space is from conan o'brien's
production company and has a voice cast
including fred armisen
ron funches and jane lynch this review
from collider really captures what makes
the show so special quote
final space swerves so severely from
comedic beats in one moment to dramatic
gut punches in the next
that you'll find yourself laughing just
before the wind gets knocked out of you
and your jaw hangs open
in disbelief couldn't agree more i love
that show
stream seasons one and two a final space
on hbo max right now new season three
episodes premiere saturdays at 10 30 p.m
only on adult swim all right marina it's
your turn to answer some questions are
you ready to take on some bite-sized
ones
yeah yeah i love braids so our first
bite-sized question is how did tony
stark get the claw marks out of captain
america's shield that comes from iaj
smith24 on discord okay so great
question
so thank you for submitting questions
guys and we have covered the properties
of vibranium before on a previous big
question right
and in that episode philip reminds us
that vibranium is a much more
malleable material than another famous
super strong element
in the marvel universe adamantium so
once something made of adamantium is
forged it becomes incredibly strong
and basically unbreakable however
vibranium can be used in many different
ways like making a solid shield
or a super strong cyber arm for a
particular white wolf
or even woven into a fine mesh like
structure that mimics
fabric right such as black panther suit
so it's with those vibranium claws
that black panther is able to make the
marks on cap's vibranium shield so
because they're made of the same
material
one is able to damage the other so a
diamond can scratch a diamond but
nothing else can tony is very familiar
with the properties of vibranium and
gets the farmer's dad uh who would know
how to work with
it and repair it so because of the
malleable properties of vibranium
and his mechanical engineering super
intelligence tony is able to fix up
capshield before he gives it back to
steve
even though it belongs to his father and
now morgan's gonna have to get a new
sled
guys oh no
how'd you get four new sled oh her dad
was a billionaire yeah she'll be fine
she'll be fine she'll slide on a person
she's like that's your job is you get
slid on that sounds like a fun job
hey money corrupts i don't care what
they say about tony stark
the more money this girl has she's gonna
grow up being a little jerk she has to
go to public school at the very she has
to go to public school
um eric they're sexual again i'm gonna
get
people mad at me for this but there's
actual real science i love to throw in
real science
there's actual real science that the
the more money you have the worse of a
person you become and it's researched
it's
research i'm sorry but it's true science
tells us
i used to think like well what about
bill gates he and melinda gates have
been so
uh philanthropic and have been i've been
so great
uh i don't think they're putting chips
in people by the way no that's not where
i'm going with this
um but but uh if you look at like his
history in the 90s
uh he only started this melinda gates
foundation after he was like a huge jerk
about antitrust uh
regulation and he came off like a huge
[ __ ] so he's like well how can i
spend my billions
why don't i do something good for the
world and since then he's become
a much a better person who has done a
lot for this world so
and also it was mostly melinda who was
like you should probably
get rid of some of this we don't know
what's going on behind those closed
doors oh i'm
there you're in those you're in that
room no but i think you are right uh
if you're rich don't let your kids know
that you have money just don't oh
yeah honestly you know who's probably
really cool is bruce willis daughter
because he was like i'm not gonna give
you any money
and you have to get a job in a shoe
store and she did good for her rumor
willis
god bless you you're hustling all right
marina another bite-sized question for
you
what are sam's wings made out of and who
designed and built them and what version
are we up to
now that was asked by old man tripper on
discord okay
let's start at the beginning so x07 suit
number one
prior to 2014 sam wilson and his wig man
riley both had
x07 winged harnesses that were designed
by stark industries
and used in afghanistan for pararescue
and extraction missions
while they were part of the air national
guard riley was shot down by an rpg
during one of those missions and it's
assumed that his x07 was destroyed
sam's x07 was then kept at fort meade
until captain america and black widow
borrowed it
so sam can team up with them to take on
the hydra members embedded in shield
along with the winter soldier this
original x07 harness is then
destroyed by the winter soldier when he
grabs sam out of the sky
tears one of the wings off and tosses
falcon off the helicarrier so this leads
us to
x07 suit number two in 2015
sam gets an upgraded version of the x07
that has similar functions to the
previous version
but as weapons armor plating
communications
sensors and that's a sweet red trim oh
baby we can assume tony stark played a
role in designing and building this
upgraded version especially since he's
bankrolling the team at this point
since shield is now out of picture right
he might
not have like literally made this suit
personally but he certainly
paid somebody to do it he oversaw it
yeah he paid yeah yeah uh
underpaid probably yeah he definitely
underpaid somebody to do
some intern look the intern is excited
so this is the x07 sam is wearing when
he shows up
to join the new avengers team um led by
captain america
we continue to see this version of the
x07 when he battles ant-man at the
avengers facility
ant-man does shrink down and do some
damage to the harness in that battle but
it's not destroyed now this is the one
that has the little
the drone right yeah exactly
so yeah you're right that's exactly
right so this x07 also gets the addition
of the red wing drone right
which we see in civil war the drone is a
nod to the actual falcon named red wing
that sam johnson had in the comics right
red wing and with that red wing he could
communicate telepathically which is
very cool so during the lagos battle the
wings are shown to be bulletproof and
sam fires off some missiles from that
suit
um this xo7 is then confiscated by the
joint counter-terror center in berlin
the city with cool separate paths the
best
sidewalks oh the best sidewalks in the
world this exo7 is then confiscated by
the joint counter-terrorist
center in berlin which is an agency
established by the cia because the wings
are
technically government property sharon
carter
does if you guys remember steal this
version and return it to sam before the
airport battle in civil war
so it's during sam's scuffle with
spider-man that peter parker asked if
the wings are made of carbon fiber
as that would explain their like
flexibility but they're also still rigid
those wings carving fiber is this stuff
coming out of you but we never really
get a confirmation that pete's correct
because they're in the middle of a
battle
but he's a smart guy so we can like
assume that he's right yeah no he knows
his uh
materials he's a child who builds
weapons yeah
trustworthy um the wings are i mean the
wings are bulletproof
sam gets captured again and then the exo
is taken
again but he gets it back at the end of
the movie
um we then see the same x07 harness in
infinity war and it gets
snapped along with sam at the end of the
film so they both disappear
um but it comes back along with him when
hulk reverses a snap in end game so
it goes away yeah it comes with him
right back it's like a badass thing you
use that to like
stab into one of these things yeah
that's what it sounds like um so it
looks like we're still only on the
second version of the x07 falcon harness
um
but eric i i mean maybe we might see a
new version
yeah it looks like a falcon winter
soldier he's got a new redesign of those
wings and they
fold inward to make a shield that they
like can hide behind like those things
are great
version three we're gonna get a three uh
i'm super excited to see
so to answer the question of what are
they made out of
and who built them carbon fiber and
stark tech yep well there you go
a tripper you got an answer
[Music]
so uh who is your completely
unorthodox fictional character crush
you can't say like uh you know uh uh
jessica rabbit
or something like that right because
she's you know humanoid in names
the hottest character ever drawn yet
that would be a traditional answer eric
no
my weird uh crush is
um [ __ ] from lady and the [ __ ] oh
because which dog because he's a dog
i remember as a kid being like oh no
what's happening he's an animal why do i
feel this way like
it stays that way forever has not
changed
i think he's sexy he's got like uh he's
not like um
the fox robin hood who's definitely
yeah but he's he's got some human-esque
personified features right his eyes are
not dog eyes he's got
big old eyes really it's the attitude
it's the lacy fair attitude you know
really i want somebody who's just gonna
abandon me eric who's your weird crush
um as a disney kid growing up in the
disney renaissance
i had uh i had interesting attractions
to
all those villains so for me it was kind
of a cross between i was really into
ursula
which i talked about before specifically
and this is where it becomes impractical
because ursula is kind of
yeah she's sexy she's thick she's eating
it super sexy when she gets big at the
end of the movie that's where i was like
oh which is completely impractical she's
like massive i don't understand
why i just was like yes good for you
i was like she is crush me
master of the ocean like yes queen
yes oh my god so between that and a
similar moment happens
in aladdin with jafar he's
like weirdly he turns into a snake i was
not into him until he becomes a snake
and he's just like let's see how much of
a snake i can be
and i was like squeeze me squeeze me
that's so funny oh my gosh it doesn't
make any sense uh
at the end so big old snake jafar and
big ol ursula
there's something about them doesn't
make any sense but i don't know if
kelly's there but
but just just sit on eric's chest and
he'll love it just he wants to be
crushed
he wants to be crushed this is i don't
think it's
i think it was just a cr literal cru or
figurative crushes again i don't think
it manifested anything
luckily for me as an adult it was just
like as a child
it would it just started something in me
as a child that's great that's great
well
you with that and me with like a literal
dog so
there you go
this better not awaken anything in me
uh well that is it for this episode of
big question
hopefully we help you find where wanda
maximoff is and find something in
yourself
that you shouldn't feel ashamed of no
don't let anybody shame you
don't let anyone shame you uh hey i want
to thank marina for joining me this
episode of big question it's been such a
delight as always marina
thanks for having me you can follow
marina at marina mastros you can follow
me at eavos follow the new rockstars
send us your big questions using the
big question subscribe to this podcast
feed give us a nice reading review
subscribe to new rockstars here on
youtube hit that notification bell
and we will see you next time bye
[Music]
you